what if you met a girl that you really
liked her right and you went on a couple
dates i really like this girl right and
then you went to her place and she had a
gigantic gandalf you know frame poster
and like orbs and like you know what i
mean like hobbit feet and she was like
so obsessed with wait you're describing
yourself
that's his fantasy he's describing right
now that's what upstairs looks like
yeah yeah but with that no because i've
met girls where like you know like even
white girls or whatever but then you go
to their house and they have num chucks
yeah like everything's like bamboo and
like they have a fetish or whatever yeah
so if they had a hobbit fetish would
that be weird
i mean
it might be a bit weird there's no
question that um
that i've hung around with people who
are
who are big on the movies yeah it was it
was a piece of pop culture it was like a
phenomenon that thing so
you know
it's it's hit a lot of people
i think most people who have seen those
movies would say i like them and then
you have people who've seen those movies
and
that is their all-time favorite thing
ever i've definitely hung out with
people like that yeah it is one of them
honestly
i think laurel the rings is one of like
i've had david when david cho was on
we referenced it all the time and
stephen young was there too right and we
just ref i reference it all the time
there are just moments in the trilogy
that just stick stable it says bible
it's my bible like the extraordinary
book
no no but genuinely you read the book no
the books i mean look the movie did a
great job with the books but if you love
the movie i'm telling you if you think
the movies are like a nine out of ten
the books are some of the most
extraordinary pieces of fiction like
it's consistently voted as the greatest
book of all time wow it's an amazing
piece of work i've never been more
intoxicated by a world than middle earth
i've read i've read books that i prefer
more i mean american psycho is probably
my favorite book oh wow and that
experience of reading american psycho
was more
enjoyable for me but in terms of like
finding yourself lost in a fantasy realm
holy [ __ ] lord of the rings is insane
yeah he
developed those characters in world war
ii i think right yeah yeah and he's on
the battlefield right and then he just
because obviously there's you're
fighting different people and this and
that i guess
i would that's what i would do i would
just because it would be so traumatic
being in a [ __ ] war that i would just
fantasize probably you know i mean yes
and try to get out of myself and those
those four hobbits represent the
privates in the army wow the four
hobbits are the the soldiers that go in
wide-eyed great let's go to war i want
to help my friends yeah and then they
come out absolutely destroyed by it all
you know tolkien is incredible tolkien
was the um head of english at oxford
university which is arguably you know
one of the most kind of notorious
universities on the planet and was also
the head of language at
oxford university he created
four or five
full languages that you can speak from
lord of the rings you can speak
hobbitish you can speak dwarvish you
speak elvish you speak high elvish so
when you go to these [ __ ] conventions
some people come over to you and talk to
you in high elvis assuming that i know
wow
what do you want me to sign
like when when um aragorn sings
is that real things he's singing yeah
that's elvish he's singing elvish yeah
it's a little weird hearing him sing
it's a little feminine
you know whatever and you're like whoa
dude that's weird yeah yeah yeah it's a
little feminine you don't sing do you
sing in it i know the pippen does i
don't sing
i'm really good at impersonating good
singers but i don't have a voice of my
own yeah so billy has a voice if you say
to billy whatever sing are you lonesome
tonight by elvis he won't sing it like
elvis he'll sing it like himself and
it'll be beautiful wow i can only sing
it like elvis but i can impersonate
elvis really well and i can impersonate
morrison really well and john lennon and
bob dylan like i'm really good at
impersonating people yeah yeah but like
my brother's a singer and my brother
would always be like yeah but where's
where's your voice how does your voice
sound i'm like i don't know what my
voice sounds like i just impersonate
people but your voice is so gritty right
right so why don't that can be your
voice right yeah but i think if i sang
it'd be more like tom waits or something
ah
yeah yeah that's why when i do an
american accent in my voice it sounds
like i'm a 75 year old man
i i would actually talk like this
that's that's not how someone who looks
like me wow you go deeper he sounds more
american than i do
100 yeah and i've been here for a long
time your whole life
i've i mean i've talked to other people
that are involved in that movie too and
especially hobbits and you guys
you guys didn't get paid that well no no
we didn't yeah yeah but people would be
astounded how little we got paid like
outside of the industry i think people
like oh you still got paid a lot in the
industry people like wait you're in
arguably one of the greatest trilogies
of movies on that all time and you
couldn't retire off it no we couldn't
get anywhere near to return that's
insane meanwhile like all the twilight
actors and the harry potter actors and
anyone in james bond and anyone in star
wars like they're all like oh this is
yes but don't you get ris you don't get
even residual you can't get residuals
what yeah yeah don't get residual you
don't get any residuals no after
after years of the lord the rings
only being beaten by star wars in terms
of the in terms of the products that we
sold from the movies so star wars is the
all-time king in terms of
you know lunch boxes and duvet sets and
you know
on cereal boxes and all that kind of
[ __ ]
loaded rings is second so in all of our
contracts it said
if you if we sell something that
includes your likeness then you will get
a certain amount of money and at one
point
viggo
spoke to new line and said hey it's been
like four or five years and none of the
actors from lord of the rings has
received any residuals from wow these
hundreds of millions of dollars of of uh
money that you've been making from the
trilogy
and
newline said to uh viggo we don't write
a check for anything less than 50 bucks
viggo's like wait you're saying that
we've made less than 50 bucks yeah the
actors and they're like yeah
how could that even be [ __ ] possible
yeah yeah we had to get like lawyers to
go in there wow what do you call it
auditing right yardage
new line which is all very sexy i
remember like talking to my friend like
what are you up to well we're just
ordering a new line right now yeah yeah
yeah but did you end up getting someone
we got some
even so
you know new line went bankrupt based on
the movies based on lord of the rings
movies lord of the rings made over two
billion dollars for for new line and
they went bankrupt so something's yeah
is that billy something is a foot
billy
is that how you're gonna do it you're
gonna do it on the phone like that
this is the only way you can do it yeah
we had some technical difficulties but
you can't you can't put it up on that tv
no yeah because he won't be able to hear
you though yeah yeah problem so
bill don't look so scared billy first of
all can i just i want to introduce my
can you hear me
yes
i'm going to go pee
go pee yeah where do i go